hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of science
and technology
so i see we have a variety of questions
queued up and happy to try and answer
other ones people might have
let's see you have one here from icy
who comments that i published several
books since my book a new kind of
science which came out just over 20
years ago now
and the question being asked is has
publishing technology and quality
changed in the intervening time
well you know a couple of things have
happened i mean publishing as an
industry
has changed a lot
because it used to be the case that to
get many copies of something out there
in the world
required investing quite a bit of money
to have a printing press print them in
since the web came into existence which
had you know had started to happen by
the time the nks book came out but with
the web
it's the economics of getting something
published for the world to see is quite
different getting people to pay
attention to what's published is a
different story but the actual sort of
act of having something out there which
can have many at least virtual copies
that people can see is a quite different
story because it used to be the case
that you know to publish a book would
cost
something in the tens of thousands of
dollars minimum to just print you know
ramp up that printing press and actually
print off copies of hundreds of pages of
documents
uh um but so that's changed and of
course there are many dynamics in the
way that books are distributed you know
the corner bookstore versus the web
distribution
versus the online bookstore and so on
that's all changed
in terms of the physical production of a
book
one thing i find interesting is that the
the value of presenting information in
book form
has
still been maintained as far as i'm
concerned one of the things that
i like about books
is that when you have something as a
book you can kind of viscerally tell
that's everything it's talking about
here it's not a question of having links
where you might follow this link and
then there might be another link to
follow and then another one you don't
really know how big the the octopus is
so to speak
um with a book there's kind of a very
definite there's this thing i flip
through it i'm going to tell how far i
am from the end and so on now obviously
that's emulated in lots of ebook kinds
of publications and formats
i still find it very you know nice to
have the physical book where i can flip
through it and get that same kind of
experience
in terms of the production of physical
books
yeah there have been a number of changes
i mean print on demand
has
become much more viable and of much
higher quality
it had been the case that you were
either using
a kind of xerography you know
photocopying type technology or you were
using offset printing and that those
would give two very different qualities
of output
those things have now
almost not completely merged i mean to
produce a book like the nks book that
was printed at very high resolution and
so on that's not possible yet in print
on demand even 20 years later
um but to produce a book that is a more
typical resolution and so on is possible
with print on demand um it's also become
the sort of the convergence of the price
of black and white and color printing
has happened so it becomes much more
realistic to print many more kinds of
things in in color
i think the um the dynamics of that have
had the effect that
when
it used to be the case that excuse me
it used to be the case
that
when you were going to print something
you kind of had to make the commitment
that you were going to print lots of it
because
it cost a lot to set up the printing
plates and to kind of initiate the
process of printing things with print on
demand you can print just one of it
and the amount that it costs to print
five of it
is roughly five times the amount it
costs to print one of it there's not
sort of a an initial startup cost
that has to be amortized across the
number of copies that you make
so uh
that's um
uh but but i think in in in general the
uh the quality of books as printed on a
printing press
um has
oh it's it's sort of still exceeds the
the quality of our eyes to be able to uh
see
higher resolution so that's kind of the
that's kind of the max that one's
reached there
and now it's only a question of whether
the kind of print-on-demand mechanism
has reached the same point
uh
let's see
oh my there's a question here about the
history of fluid mechanics
how the navier-stokes equations were
discovered and how they work
i'm not sure i know this history all
that well
um
the
the question of sort of how fluids flow
uh the bernoullis
looked at that in i think the 1600s
leading to
these principles about uh
uh pressure versus velocity and so on um
then
the
uh
i think the early 1800s
people started thinking about fluid
mechanics as something to which you
could apply the laws of mechanics
i mean in the in the early days of
mechanics people were most interested in
things like
solid bodies and talking about
well motion of planets things like that
eventually the rather elaborate
equations of the motion of things like
tops
things that were sort of relevant to the
industrial revolution and things that
were uh you know stresses and strains
and iron structures things like this
those were things that were studied in
in the context of solid mechanics
as the 1800s kind of rolled on by the
1860s people were interested in things
like molecular dynamics
of thinking about how lots of molecules
bouncing around would uh
obeying the laws of mechanics what the
aggregate effect of that would be
i think the um the navier-stokes
equations and things like that were in
the slightly earlier part of the 1800s
and i think one of the things that have
been done there was prasos equation
which is the equation that tells one the
um
the rate of flow of fluid in a tube
fluid with a certain viscosity in a tube
and um i'm not quite sure when the
concept of viscosity the kind of the uh
the sort of resistance to motion in a
fluid uh the analog of friction for a
fluid um when that was first studied
people certainly observed that uh you
know water pours more easily than syrup
pores but the measurement of viscosity
as a
as something that
would characterize the sort of flowing
of fluids when you put a certain
pressure on a fluid
how much will its will it flow i'm not
sure when that really took off
now uh the plus a equation
was for
uh the amount of fluid given a certain
pressure of fluid how much fluid would
flow through a
tube and that was i think originally
studied in connection with the rather
gruesome question of if you sort of cut
open
the artery of a horse
how much blood will flow out of it now
by the way ironically enough blood is a
very strange kind of fluid um not least
because red blood cells are this kind of
flexible kind of flying saucer-like
shape that gets deformed and so on as it
goes through uh it gets aligned with the
flow it deforms as it goes through small
capillaries things like this
um so it's a it's a somewhat uh peculiar
kind of fluid
that um is not a newtonian fluid ah
there's a clue for me about when
viscosity first got discussed
because uh i i'm guessing newton i don't
actually know specifically where he
discussed this
but um uh i i'm guessing newton must
have discussed viscosity because the
most common form
of of type of viscosity that the that
the shearing force leads to a certain
velocity um that is called uh
uh flow
um
and sort of the the different thing that
happens with materials that don't have
this kind of linear dependence
of flow rate on shear force
um
the that um uh that that um those are
called non-newtonian flow so i'm
guessing newton had discussed the idea
of viscosity somewhere um perhaps
uh not unrelated to
what newton discussed in the in his law
of cooling that says that a thing
uh
his estimate was that the rates at which
something cools is proportional to the
difference in temperature between the
thing and the surrounding air um in
reality there are different forms of
cooling depending on whether there's
convection of just the air kind of uh
hot air rising from the object or or
coming off the object and being
exchanged with the environment versus
forced convection where you're kind of
blowing across something uh forced
convection is more like the newtonian
version free convection is more like a
five-fourths power i think of that
temperature difference
but so i guess newton must have known
about viscosity um i i don't know
at what point oh yes actually there was
also work done
on the shape of liquid drops
um and that will have been something
which made use of
ideas of fluid mechanics
and
that was certainly happening
by the mid-1800s
because people were discussing both
liquid drops and things about the
formation of planets and so on from from
kind of fluid-like forms
the
the navier-stokes equations
um
have uh
well they have different terms that
probably came in in different times
um there's the the main term the
inertial piece
it's uh you know the the time rate of
change of velocity um plus v dot grad v
um that's a nonlinear term that is is
quadratic in the viscosity equals uh
uh
eta
del squared v so eta is the viscosity
there's also a a density which i omitted
on the left hand side so that what
actually appears in sort of the ratio of
these terms
is um uh the so-called kinematic
viscosity the ordinary shear viscosity
divided by uh the um the density of the
fluid but the the right hand side the
the del squared v thing in the naive
stokes equations that's a representation
of viscous flow
um and uh
uh i think that might have come in
earlier than the representation of sort
of inertial flow on the on the left-hand
side but essentially what happens in the
navy stokes equations they describe the
velocity in fluids and the right-hand
side describes the tendency of fluids to
just damp out
uh velocity so you start a fluid running
and the the sort of effectively the
friction in the fluid the analog of
friction for a liquid or for a fluid
will cause that motion to get damped out
the left hand side is about if you start
something in motion it will continue it
has sort of has uh inertia to continue
that motion and so for example that's
what tells you that an eddy that you
start off in a fluid will keep going as
an eddie now that left hand side um it
has
well the combination of these two pieces
has much more complicated effect that
for example roughly makes a big eddy
tend to break up into smaller eddies and
still smaller eddies until eventually
the eddies are small enough that they
get damped away by viscosity but this
cascade of eddies that was an idea of
kamagaroffs from the
1930s i think um
as a kind of way of describing
turbulence in fluids this the sort of
apparently random motion that you see in
fluids um that's uh
that's something that comes from that
inertial part of the navi stokes
equations and the ratio of kind of the
inertial term to the viscosity term is
called the reynolds number and that sort
of characterizes the nature of flows and
that was some
oswald reynolds right in the
late 1800s so again people uh studying
fluid dynamics but i think reynolds
mostly observed that
if you
look at sort of a a bigger but slower
thing then it will have the same pattern
of fluid flow as a faster but smaller
thing that all that matters is the
reynolds number which is the uh uh the
the um
a ratio of velocities and and lengths
and viscosities and so on
so i'm i i don't know this in as much
detail as um as i would like uh i the
more recent history of flow mechanics i
i know better
but uh
the um oh gosh
well let's see i mean fluid mechanics
as it developed in the 1900s
um
people sort of had the basic equations
and then there was a big push to sort of
find uh solutions to those equations and
so
uh in the case of laminar flow flow
where everything is smooth where there
isn't turbulence there's not this sort
of
a random motion and so on in case of
laminar flow
the big push
i would say in the late 1800s was to
find exact solutions in terms of various
kinds of mathematical functions and so
for example uh stokes
found this thing called it's usually
called stokes flow
and uh for example if you look at flow
past a sphere um you can work out
exactly what the drag on the sphere is
associated with the the motion of fluid
around it um 6 pi 80 av as i recall um
and
that's a nice kind of traditional
uh sort of 19th century mathematical
physics calculation
to know what happens when the flow is
faster and when you start getting for
example vortices that break off behind
the object that becomes much more
difficult and
things like vortex streets
were observed forever
but there still isn't a good analytical
theory of those things in terms of
traditional mathematical functions now
it has to be said in the uh people had
uh wind tunnels
and they had kind of visualization of
fluids certainly in the 1800s i think
there was a big boon in the
making of of wind tunnels and other
fluid mechanics
uh experiments in the 1930s strangely
enough it seems like a bunch of large
wind tunnel and fluid dynamics labs were
constructed at that time in the u.s
as part of the wpa works program
administration i guess
sort of finding work after the great
depression
um uh plan uh one of the things that was
done during that time was let's go build
wind tunnels and so a bunch got built
which are often still in use today
um
so
that led to kind of the ability to study
in the lab various kinds of fluid
mechanics
um people
had uh been interested in sort of
empirical fluid mechanics from the time
when people were making kites to the
time of the wright brothers
and to the time of other kinds of
aeroplane discussions so to speak
i just saw actually a rather charming
picture
talking of kites
of a
alexander graham bell was a was a
lover of exotically shaped kites
and one that i just saw a picture of was
a a a three-dimensional fractal sipinsky
uh
uh tetrahedral kite
that he had in the very beginning of the
1900s i think
um that he was flying and actually it's
strange because i think that time
is comparable to the time when sapinsky
was first talking about those fractal
patterns and when people like ninja were
talking about men's sponges and and
three-dimensional uh kind of fractal
patterns and just a little bit after
when when georg cantor was talking about
cantor sets
as the sort of uh uh
which which later became sort of uh uh
identified as sort of a minimal example
of of fractal kinds of things
um but in any case i think that the um
uh the interest in in wind tunnels and
um
uh
sort of understanding fluid mechanics
more scientifically
uh certainly was there even from the
first airplane experiments
and um i think the wright brothers had a
wind tunnel if i remember correctly in
which they could test wing designs and
so on
um uh where you're blowing air across
across this design rather than having to
take it out and make the thing go fast
in the air so to speak you're blowing
air past the design
i think that the uh
sort of the sort of development of
ideas in fluid mechanics
and
the study of kind of wing designs and so
on developed
through the first decades of the of the
1900s
and um
by
uh
things had gotten fairly sophisticated
by the 1930s and 1940s there were a
whole variety of labs
popping up
particularly as jet engines started to
be developed there were you know the jet
propulsion lab in in pasadena california
um was coming into existence that was
some and there were a lot of people who
had come out of um
there was a lot of work done in germany
um
uh
before and during the second world war
on um on fluid mechanics kinds of things
there was also sort of competing work uh
famously um there was work done on
things like the design of the wings of
the spitfire plane
in in england um where one of the things
that happened was the use of kind of
numerical methods
to find approximations to the fluid
equations um
previously sort of the choice had been
you either find an exact solution with
mathematical functions or you test the
design in a wind tunnel this was kind of
the beginning of numerical computation
where you just found a numerical
approximation to the behavior of fluids
and used that to make designs the
original work done by i think richard
southwell if i remember correctly
was done uh
using having humans be the ones who
divided up the uh the wings into a grid
of squares and then worked out if the
fluid was flowing at this rate on this
square then it would be flowing at that
rate on that square on the next step and
so on of course that by the time uh by
by about 19 the late 1940s 1950 or so um
those kinds of things just starting to
be done on computers early effort in
that regard was von neumann and charney
working in 1950 on the first numerical
weather prediction
taking the equations of fluid mechanics
and putting them on a digital computer
um
i think the uh
uh
it's sort of interesting and maybe not
the point here so what progress has been
made since then um
there have been
you know the navier stokes equations are
fundamentally hard to solve
and they're hard to solve because you
end up with a
a wide range of scales
of behavior
uh so for example those eddies that i
was mentioning you could have a very big
eddy that's the size of an airplane and
it can get broken down into very little
eddies that are like an inch across and
there are a lot of those that fit in the
size of a large airplane and you have to
kind of model all of those to be able to
figure out things about the flow around
the airplane typically on a plane has a
reynolds number of about 10 10 million
for a big plane
um and uh it um so it has a above
valence number about 100 usually get
turbulent flow so it has lots of
turbulent flow um but it has uh uh also
a lot of flow that is um uh that you can
um approximate without viscosity
but like one inch above the wings of the
plane
you get
this boundary layer where where lots of
features of viscosity really matter and
half the drag on the plane is probably
associated with what happens in that one
inch layer so it's kind of a complicated
thing to model because you've got to be
able to deal with all these different
scales of behavior
and
the uh there are lots of kinds of
empirical approximations that have been
done for sort of doing engineering
for uh um
analytical engineering and so on there
are lots of approximations that have
been made um that work fairly well but
they're not deeply principled versions
of sort of a correct modeling of the
navier-stokes equations usually what's
done is to add what's called an eddy
viscosity that is supposed to be a way
of approximating all this randomness and
the turbulence um with something that's
sort of an empirical kind of thing and
it has to be said that a lot of the work
that's been done on things like
numerical fluid mechanics has been done
in a very engineering oriented way of
just the important question is to get an
answer that is practically useful for
studying um uh actual uh flows
around planes and things not
understanding the principles of how
turbulence works with the navier-stokes
equations i myself worked on on that
second question quite a bit in the 1980s
it was very frustrating to find that the
navy stokes equations uh one didn't
really
know many very basic things about them
like for example
does it matter in the end that fluids
are made of molecules
well usually one imagines one could just
approximate fluids by these continuous
equations
but does it matter for example in
understanding turbulence perfectly does
it matter that in the end there's these
little sensitive effects that will be
associated with molecules that might get
amplified into some of the randomness
and turbulence or does that not matter
and that's still not not known i mean
that's a sort of a
a key it's related to sort of a key
unsolved problem about navi stokes
equations and about mathematical physics
in general
but uh you know when i was working on
this in the 1980s my main
uh idea was to not start from these
continuum navier-stokes equations that
describe the continuous flow of fluids
but instead start with something that
approximates the underlying molecules
start with a little you know grid of
where molecules might be a cellular
automaton
and then look at sort of scaling that up
and saying if the grid is big enough
we'll get something that approximates
what we see in the real world
as an alternative to saying let's take
the continuous equations and let's to
put them on a computer break them down
into discrete numerical pieces
and that approach of mine has had some
success
in uh in studying various kinds of
things i think it still has more to run
in terms of understanding sort of what
it means about the foundations of
turbulence and you can see with that
approach that sort of the origin of
randomness and turbulence is not the
little details of molecules it rather is
kind of the the overall kind of dynamics
of
of of
of the sort of computation that makes
the fluid flow
in a sense i i view turbulence as one of
the
places where computational
irreducibility where sort of
sophisticated computation is immediately
visible so to speak in the world and
that's something you see from these
models you don't really get to see that
very well from the navier-stokes
equations
there's lots more to say about this but
let me let me not go on with this
um
i see a question here
about
a ufos from kermit here
do i have any thoughts on uh on ufos and
um how
should one engage with conspiracy
theories or alternative science
these kinds of things you know it's
funny i i
i got talked into um
uh
well
no actually i i was uh
i got
invited to be part of
a um
a group that's trying to study what
these days is
um more
delicately called unidentified aerial
phenomena rather than unidentified
flying objects
and the the idea is
to just have a bunch of devices that are
cameras and radio receivers and audio
receivers and so on and put a bunch of
these devices around the us
kind of looking up into the sky and just
record continuously from them and just
see what's out there and actually i just
saw what was it a couple weeks ago now
the first demo device from this project
that uh have been constructed it wasn't
terribly sophisticated yet had just
infrared cameras and various kinds of
radio receivers and so on um and i think
it's just now being put into operation
and i think it will be kind of
interesting to see kind of if you just
start observing sort of uh 24 7 365 days
a year um sort of what's what's up there
um what will you see
well uh
you will no doubt see a variety of
meteorological phenomena that have not
been well characterized um you'll no
doubt
see the occasional weird experimental
aircraft that um
one didn't necessarily know was was out
there
um those kinds of things
will one see the strange kind of um
uh
uh sort of
ufos of
uh from the 1950s type
type things well you know when you talk
to people about this people
uh
will be very convinced that they've seen
kind of you know flying saucer-like
objects
and that they've seen things that glow
and things that move too quickly to be
uh
things that would be any kind of
propulsion that we know how to make
those kinds of things
what do you make of all this stuff well
you know i think it's one of these kinds
of things where one shouldn't dismiss it
out of hand
one shouldn't immediately rush to
conclude that you know
the extraterrestrial alien intelligences
are here watching us
and have been for the last 50 years or
something but i think
when there are phenomena particularly
ones that are somewhat repeatedly
reported by people uh one has to think
that it's something you know maybe it's
some strange meteorological phenomenon
maybe it's uh something about some quirk
of human perception
um in the case of some atmospheric
uh phenomena i mean one could say gosh
you know there's a rainbow how could
there possibly be a rainbow you know the
rainbow must be
some special new kind of uh uh
microorganism that's in the uh you know
in the air producing different colors
but of course we know that it's not
but rainbows are something which are
well not formed as a matter of human
visual perception but certainly closely
related to that i mean they're formed as
a result of of total internal reflection
of light in raindrops and the the
different uh uh the different refractive
index the different uh bending angles of
light of different colors different
frequencies in raindrops
but it's still something where the the
imaging of a rainbow is not a totally
obvious thing the fact that you can form
an image of a rainbow is something that
does depend on kind of the way that we
image things same same with other kinds
of phenomena like mirages
like uh the glory another another type
of sort of a circular rainbow like thing
that you can see looking down on clouds
from from airplanes and so on um and uh
so you know i think there are there are
plenty of phenomena
which can be
uh
interesting to see
and where one of the trickinesses i
would say is that there are phenomena
that
uh are visually detectable but really
depend on the on the observer so so
another one that's sort of a an example
of that is uh shadow bands in total
solar eclipses i've seen two total solar
eclipses in my life uh kind of an
interesting phenomenon to see
but uh one of the things that's been
reported in in total solar eclipses is
that right before totality if you look
down on the ground there's this kind of
shimmering that you see uh where there's
kind of this um uh the sort of
dark and light
shimmering bands
so
one total solar eclipse that i saw i
didn't see that the other total solar
eclipse i saw i saw it and it's like i
had my phone i was trying to take a
video of it the video was basically
blank
it was a phenomenon that
is for whatever reason perceptible by
humans and possibly part of human visual
perception but not very easy i think it
has been captured um by uh you know
standard ccd cameras and things but it
isn't easy to capture that way
so again that's a place where things can
get kind of funky in terms of what
people think they see versus what
cameras pick up and so on
um now
you know in
what should one do when people earnestly
tell one that they are convinced that
you know in fact i was at this event
just a couple weeks ago and somebody
with perfectly
sober person
was sort of rather guiltily telling me
well you know one afternoon
they had seen
uh you know basically a flying saucer
and uh you know i when i asked said what
shape is it well they said well it
really was a flying saucer shape
um and uh you know certainly
uh
you know my sort of uh the human level
um
that person definitely believes they saw
that thing
and
that was their perception that they saw
that thing now what was it
was it a a visitor from torcetti in a uh
a conveniently saucer shaped spacecraft
or was it some uh meteorological or
atmospheric or or physical perception
phenomenon
uh
well hard to know for sure
i would uh bet against the um
uh the the saucer shaped spaceship from
torcetti
um
but
you know
i would say that an interesting thing
about about science and the way the
dynamics that it has
is
there are things people start to believe
and then everybody kind of believes that
and
even if it isn't true
so
you know there have been plenty of times
in the history of science i mean one
might say in modern times certain
aspects of what people believe about
quantum computing
is kind of uh
you know charming for the fact that
there's a giant herd that believes it
and there's a lot of sort of economic
dynamics around that
that makes it sort of assumed to be true
whether or not the ultimate science can
be picked away to be found to be correct
it doesn't mean that it isn't worth
studying because there probably are
other very useful things about about
studying the formalism of quantum
mechanics and and sort of the the
physics of of computers that aren't made
from semiconductors and electronics
but the question of whether sort of the
full brand of it really does things
quantum
in a quantum way
i kind of doubt that that's really right
um but nevertheless
that is something where the the vast
mass of people would just say of course
that's right
um
and uh perhaps that's not the best
example i mean i suppose there are some
examples in medicine
one pretty famous one is this stomach
ulcer story
where you know back i don't know 25
years ago or something now um people
would regularly say oh i'm having too
much stress at work i you know i've got
too much stress at work that's why i
have an ulcer
and um you know i need to cut back on my
stress at work and you know my my doctor
is telling me to do that there had been
people who had said from a long for a
long time that that things like that
were an infection i think a bacterial
infection of some kind but sort of the
vast mass of belief was no no it's you
know a response to stress and so on and
it turned out in the end it was a
bacterial infection
and and that's a uh you know it's a case
where where the the masses didn't really
quite have it right now you know in
these phenomena where
you
kind of uh
um
you know there's a sort of a question in
in today's world a lot of the conspiracy
theories around ufos and so on
center around does the government know
stuff or do governments know stuff
that people in general don't know
and i think there have been different
times in history where that's been more
and less true
my guess is that the current time in
history
it's it's not very true that
the there are uh
you know there are there are few
large secrets so to speak i mean i think
um
uh i'm reminded of something i think
attributed to machiavelli that it's very
hard to keep a big conspiracy secret
um
it's uh you know if there's only a
couple of people involved well you might
be able to keep it secret but by the
time it's a big thing that's affecting a
lot of stuff it's hard to keep it secret
i think that
um
there are
uh sort of a question actually of uh
well why should you know let's say
that the government knew about
uh whatever that means because it's some
particular part of the government no
doubt
knew about
lots of kinds of you know oh actually
there are extraterrestrials dropping in
every tuesday afternoon type thing
um you know
uh
why wouldn't they tell the world
well
it's uh
um
uh
i think the um sort of a prevailing
theory of that would be
well
uh
in sort of a military way of thinking
about things if you don't know what to
do about it
uh
why would you tell people it was
happening so to speak because the
obvious question would be you know if
if
if it turns out the extraterrestrials
visit every tuesday and maybe the
extraterrestrials are dangerous or
whatever else people would immediately
say so what are you going to do about it
and if you have no idea what you're
going to do about it better to not tell
anybody it's happening and to not have
that question have to be asked than to
have everybody ask that question
um
but i think
the uh
uh you know there are there are also one
can imagine
uh well i i think
this um
uh
i i tend to think
that
there's there's sort of a question of of
when you hear about things
that
seem
completely wacky
sometimes
they really are completely wacky
sometimes there's a particular person
who is
confused in some way
uh
you know has a
some sort of uh different view of
reality
in some way that really isn't
something of of general interest i tend
to think when enough people report sort
of similar things that there's probably
something behind it it may not be the
the the big conspiratorial thing that
people think is the most exciting thing
that could be behind it but there's
probably something going on there
as i say there's something
you know i would put my
bet on
something
perhaps
not
scientifically trivial
but
not of profound scientific significance
but one can't really tell that until
once been able to kind of uh
nail things down
there was another question that got
asked here ah if i can get my
up
let me see what's happening here
has my computer decided to
misbehave here so that i can't see any
more questions
hmm very odd
that is very very odd let me see
i'm uh
that's an interesting challenge
okay let me see what i can do here
hmm
very odd
i lost my mouse
um
hold on
all right let's see computer survival
skills
that's really odd
um
okay i can bring up
anything that is keyboard navigable i
can bring up but i have no mouse
let me see how i can deal with that
isn't there a suspicious correlation
between the surge in ufo sightings since
the 1950s that is a
associated with a surge of ufo
movies during that period of time
well yes
um
the uh
you know that there's certainly
uh one would suspect
that
the movies came first
i mean i i think that the um i don't
think
that the writers of the movies
were deeply tied into the ufo sighting
community i think uh you know so there
isn't really a flow from that side it's
not like
oh um
i must say i i was struck by i was this
event about the unidentified aerial
phenomena a couple weeks ago
and uh
there was a person there who was talking
about these things who'd been involved
in sort of the military
side of of uh studying
uh ufos uaps whatever else
and i was certainly
uh quite charmed that
uh really was very much the kind of
figure
that you see in movies
as
the the sort of the the model of the
kind of military person who's involved
in the response to uh to aliens and so
on i was particularly interested having
done a bit of work on the on the movie
arrival which was an alien first contact
movie um that featured some sort of uh
interaction between uh where where
really the military were in charge of
the response to um uh to sort of the the
alien first contact and it was i was
kind of charmed to have a chance to meet
in person somebody who was just very
much like the um the characters
portrayed in in that movie and uh i
suppose kudos to the um director and uh
screenwriter and so on that movie for
having having captured the um uh
uh something quite realistic about about
that kind of response i think it's a
very interesting question
if
you know in the scenario of that movie
and others about sort of a a convincing
alien first contact so to speak you know
what
what would happen in the world what
should happen in the world
what
uh
you know i tend to think i've talked
about this at great length um this whole
notion of of extraterrestrial
intelligence is kind of a flawed notion
and that there's sort of intelligence
all over the universe and it's really a
question of as i would put it in in
terms of our modern approaches to things
sort of how far away in rural space is
that intelligence how incoherent with
our way of thinking about things is the
operation of that intelligence if it's
as close as as you know cats and dogs we
can have some sort of form of
communication
if it's as far away as the weather it's
hard for us to have sort of a a
communication with it but
notwithstanding that let's imagine that
there actually is
you know
alien intelligence that is close in
rural space that really is well aligned
with our ways of thinking about things
but it just hasn't happened to be very
nearby in physical space and one day it
arrives in a spacecraft um and then the
question is uh sort of in that situation
where things are close in real space
where we can understand
what that is
and
but where there are differences
it's not it's not like
oh i guess
you know your planet got seated with the
exact same sort of early life as ours
did and we've both grown up the same way
and ended up at the same moment in
history with uh you know slightly
differently shaped um uh creatures but
basically all the same stuff
assume that it's far enough away to be
interesting but not so far away that we
can't understand what it is or how to
how to
uh recognize or communicate with it
um so assume that that happens assume
also if it's coming in a in an
interstellar travel spacecraft it's a
bit more sophisticated than we are
because we don't have interstellar
travel spacecraft yet um
and uh it's not even clear what the what
the sort of human dynamics of having
such a thing uh to transport humans as
opposed to having some kind of automated
device that we send out and that
eventually you know generations from now
sends back results
um where we probably say oh my gosh that
had such a primitive computer on it um
you know we can barely understand how
how it's uh how it's sending things back
but but independent of that there
there's enough universality to
computation that i would be confident
that one still could sort of decode and
understand the the form of alien
intelligence that will be on that
spacecraft going out into interstellar
space
but assume that sort of the the
interstellar spacecraft arrives
and uh uh something
sort of uh emerges from it and it kind
of says hello more or less in a way that
we can we can more or less understand
what does that seem like to the world
you know
there was obviously a time
uh up until well
basically
through the 1700s i would i would say
where where there was still
kind of certainly in the 1600s there was
much
many parts of the world that were
unexplored
to the
folks who were at least writing the
histories of what was being explored
you know could there be a city of gold
in the amazon jungle
could there be the lost city of atlantis
somewhere could there even be
uh you know the city of troy somewhere
that had been written about in homer but
which had one hadn't had sort of uh
continuing evidence of
and i think
the
you know there was sort of the mystery
of what was out there in the world
and people were quite regularly sort of
expecting to see things they'd never
seen before well it turned out troy was
real
the the city of gold in the middle of
the amazon jungle probably not quite i
mean maybe it was some reflection of
some inca kind of thing the city of
atlantis well we still don't know quite
on that one
but you know it was it was pretty
routine to say
there'll be creatures we've never seen
before that are hanging out
in some uh weird jungle somewhere and
you know or on on you know the the the
bigfoot
in the um uh
uh in the mountains somewhere whatever
else people routinely expected that
there will be discoveries
and sort of uh
new and unexpected things now they do
such discoveries do keep on coming in
because particularly you know who knew
that they were going to be sort of uh
very sulfur friendly forms of life in
hydrothermal vents in the ocean where
people were initially always way too hot
for there to be life we don't know for
example whether there's life
deep underground in the earth there
might be it might be very weird
we don't know
you know we learnt that there's life in
the deep oceans
uh far below where light ever gets you
know we thought for a while all those
fish were spherical because when you
take a thing that's a very you know a
fish that lives under very high pressure
you pull it up the surface it it kind of
inflates like a balloon um but in fact
they're not spherical um and uh i
remember people explaining why they had
to be spherical one of those interesting
science moments
but it turns out they're not spherical
they just seem to be spherical because
they're spherical when they blow up like
a balloon after you pull them out of the
deep ocean and bring them to a much
lower pressure
but i think that the um
the thing that uh
uh sort of this idea that there's weird
stuff still to discover
and weird life forms and so on
is a is a thing that mostly we've
decided that's not going to happen much
more on earth
i'm not even sure that's true i mean the
archaeoba the the archaea were
discovered what
30 years ago or something
um
[Music]
um
uh the
um the fingered
by
tur at microscopy and genomics so to
speak uh rather than it's it's sort of a
that was a case where a new form of life
was all around us
i kind of like the way i think it's
going to go with it with alien
intelligence that eventually will
realize new forms of intelligence are
all around us so to speak rather than
you have to go out somewhere in space to
find it but i still coming back to this
question of what is it like
when
kind of the
the alien intelligence that we can
recognize shows up
well obviously in in earlier times in
history when kind of western
uh
explorers
showed up in places that had been
previously
uh you know isolated
that was a type of thing that feels a
little bit like what the alien
extraterrestrials
might be like showing up now
and uh you know one knows stories of
what happened
when you know people showed up in the
americas or whatever else
um and
there were
uh probably some good consequences and
some bad consequences
um one thing that i find surprising
about many of those stories is how easy
communication was to establish
one might have thought oh you're you're
there in a place where there's no common
language
but you don't really read about
a lot of oh my gosh there had to be all
this work done figuring out translation
tables and making dictionaries and so on
pretty much
one gets the impression people manage to
communicate now
uh perhaps that's because there's enough
commonality in the human condition
whether you come from sort of fanciest
elizabethan england or something or
whether you come from
uh sort of the uh
uh
you know the indigenous peoples of the
americas or something that um even
though the um uh the kind of um state of
development of let's say technology
other kinds of things might be different
and the kinds of cultural beliefs and
interests might be different but there's
still enough sort of commonality in the
basic human condition
everybody you know eats and sleeps and
and those kinds of things and and talks
for that matter um albeit in different
languages um that uh uh you know that
there's uh
let me give you something that um is
nice to eat
or you know perhaps there's enough
commonality of let me give you this
shiny object that uh everybody thinks is
cool because it's a shiny object and
everybody thinks shiny objects are cool
um the uh you know there's enough
commonality there that was possible to
establish communication i would think
more easily than i would expect
so you know but of course that's just
humans to humans
and and of course we've had a a dismal
record of establishing communications
with other species living on our own
planet so that doesn't give one a huge
amount of of hope i think
for uh uh sort of the the alien
intelligence situation i mean one might
argue well look
we are you know
as we get more sophisticated we're going
to be able to communicate more easily
well okay let's have that conversation
with the whale and then i'll be more
convinced about that we're not yet in a
position to do that maybe we will be
fairly soon but we're not yet
um and that would uh that would kind of
make it um uh something where i might be
more convinced that the the sort of the
quotes more advanced version of
something like us would have a an easier
time communicating with us but again
there's so many hypotheticals here
because to even have the possibility of
recognizing that it's a a kind of a
thing like us as opposed to you know oh
that was an interstellar rock
we say it's an interstellar rock to
somebody else they say look there are
all these you know complicated uh
electronic processes going on inside the
rock
didn't you know that's really a whole
extraterrestrial civilization that's
been hanging out on the rock traveling
from star systems a star system for the
last billion years um you just uh were
too
ignorant to notice all of those sort of
electronic processes which to someone
else
might read as the sophisticated
civilization to us it just reads as
they're a bunch of electronic processors
in iraq
so you know i think it's it's it's it's
complicated there are many sort of
stacks of hypotheticals when you imagine
something which kind of uh comes through
physical space to to visit us and is
close enough to us
that that we kind of uh
can really
empathize with what it is
um but again it leaves one with the
question of what would happen in today's
world um if
that hypothetical came came to be
and uh you know we kind of got
confronted with let's say a more
sophisticated civilization i i have to
say
that
i think
there will be a lot more
it's like when we look at computers and
ais and things and and
ais are able to do some things that are
sort of more sophisticated than than um
uh than we are but um
it um
uh
uh
we
don't as immediately become
it's kind of less
uh what can i say the features of ais
that are alien
are ones that we say oh we don't care
about that what we care about are the
features of ais that are deeply aligned
with us
and those places where the ais kind of
zoom off
into the into the sunset doing things
that are much more sophisticated in some
sense than the things that we do all
those little details of how the inside
of a machine learning system works those
are things where we say oh those are
just details of the inside of a machine
learning system we don't care about
those we only care whether the system
says it's a cat or a dog in the end so
to speak and i have the slight feeling
that you know if the if the
sophisticated extraterrestrials show up
and they're doing all this kind of stuff
and they've got all these kind of
streams of i don't know what fluid that
they're exchanging in this way and
they're making all these drops in the
air and they're doing all these
elaborate things let's say
and and we'd kind of shrug and say well
that's nice
you know i don't know why they're doing
it
it's kind of cool looking but who cares
um there might be things that the aliens
were doing where we would say yeah we've
really wanted to do that we've talked
about that we haven't been able to do it
we know what it is but we haven't been
able to do it many of those things are
things that have specifically showed up
in things like science fiction we've
been able to imagine it but we haven't
been able to do it we've been able to
imagine teleportation but we haven't
been able to do it
uh you know now of course what does that
really mean i mean does it mean you scan
the object you break it down into atoms
you send a digital signal about it you
reconstruct it from atoms at the other
end that's kind of a very uh
that seems like a very prosaic form of
teleportation but you know seeing it in
action that might be what would happen
um and i think uh and we might then say
oh that isn't really teleportation even
though it has the effect of the thing
that we've been thinking about as
teleportation but but i think that you
know the real question is are will the
aliens be doing things that we know we
would care about but we just haven't
been able to do
would they be doing things that we just
can't imagine why anybody would do that
and so they just don't they don't read
as something that's relevant to us i
mean it's you know we might say look at
those aliens
they are performing all these rituals
which you know look at them they're
doing this and they're doing that and
they're they're twiddling themselves
around and they're doing this kind of
thing and they're doing that kind of
thing you know they must have some
elaborate you know cultural belief
system that leads them to follow these
kinds of rituals um you know and we sort
of shrug and say well we don't have that
belief system so we don't care
but in fact to them those quotes rituals
might be the kind of the the you know
they might be the kind of uh
uh
you know the the social media like
uh clicking mechanism for the uh for the
aliens might be something that is some i
don't know physical motion type thing or
something
you know they're swiping
left or right or whatever they might be
doing and you see that as some bizarre
sort of thing where we don't know what
the point of it is
um and uh uh and so we we just can't
can't
uh connect to it right i have to solve
this problem i either have to give up
for today or i have to solve my oh look
at that my mouse is back
hello mouse
all right okay that means i can go on
just a little bit here
um
um
okay there are questions here about um
um
[Music]
uh
all right uh parker is commenting on a
an effect something i don't know about
about the phoenix lights event where
thousands of people saw the exact same
thing yeah i mean a lot of these
unidentified aerial phenomena things
it's like a lot of people see the same
rainbow
um and
that's not a ufo
uh the fact that a lot of people see the
same thing
means there's probably something to
explain there
it might be something that is related to
human perception many people can see the
same shadow bands yet they're hard to to
uh uh to record properly um i think that
uh
uh
you know i i agree that there's things
to explain um they don't necessarily uh
you know there's a
it would be um
a different thing
to uh
uh
be able to say i i i just be personally
i'd be very surprised
if we could identify a thing and say
that's a um
that's kind of a
uh an identifiable sort of uh
um
you know
aliens like us spacecraft kind of thing
you know one of the things
that also is worth saying is that
there
are you know one can imagine all kinds
of strange things that go on like for
example supersonic planes
produce sonic booms people claim one
might be able to reduce the amount of
sonic
booms from the shock fronts if one if
one carefully shapes the plane and
things like this but but sonic booms
uh actually travel through the air quite
long distances and so you know people
they'll be sort of blown by the wind and
things like this and and people will end
up hearing them in places where it's
like there's no supersonic plane going
nearby but yet there's this strange
phenomenon that happens
and you know i can quite believe there
are plenty of
astronomical uh and
um
uh um atmospheric phenomena
you know kinds of um
auroras and uh forms of bull lightning
all kinds of things which uh we don't
yet know about and um
uh that's some
uh you know
those are things that are interesting
they're probably not as interesting as
we just discovered an alien civilization
but they might be interesting physics
who knows ball lightning this phenomenon
where you can get this kind of ball of
glowing ball
that uh forms and lasts for a few
minutes and maybe bounces around a room
and so on and is you know i don't know a
meter across or something like this
but that happens sometimes in
thunderstorms a rare phenomenon
occasionally seen
uh you know probably that's some
some sort of uh plasma soliton like
thing that's a kind of a a stable form
of plasma
that we don't otherwise know about
um and it's probably a perfectly real
thing that somebody could figure out
eventually oh yes once i see how it
works i can solve the magneto
hydrodynamic equations and say yes that
thing should exist but i wouldn't have
ever guessed it would exist without
having seen one so there are probably
plenty of things like that
um there's a question here about other
notable phenomena that people thought
they've observed that were
not proven to have scientific validity
example alchemy
yeah alchemy is an interesting case i i
don't um
um
i think
that
you know alchemy was was something
practiced in the middle ages
particularly kind of the idea that sort
of an early kind of chemistry where you
could make something remarkable from
something unremarkable particularly make
gold from lead for example
and
i would say one of the things that's
probably a trickiness in an area like
alchemy
is
that
it was
probably
the obvious payoff of making gold from
lead
is not the best influence on having sort
of the most accurate science done
and i would say that with alchemy
it is a little surprising to me and i
don't know enough about the history of
alchemy to know for sure
that
you know in the end
it must have been possible
to
uh you know somebody says well i made
some gold well of course they could just
have had the gold in their back pocket
and they pull it out
um
and uh
uh you know my impression is that the
sort of practices of alchemy really did
turn into the practices of chemistry
um it's just that the kind of the
overarching story was a bit different
now i mean the same can be said about
astrology
um you know astrology
was kind of a thing where you know
practiced in ancient babylon
and where people were sort of
foretelling the future by doing a
variety of things from looking at the
entrails of goats
to looking at uh sort of the arrangement
of of stars and planets and so on
um
and
you know astrology one branch of it
turned into astronomy um because it was
all about sort of uh in the end the
predictions you might make might be
predictions about where planets would be
and turns out one figured out how to
make those using essentially mathematics
um the other predictions about kind of
uh you know who will win this or that
battle one didn't figure out how to make
in the same kind of scientific ways um
and uh but i think
the
uh
there's a certain sense to me
in which i imagine the ancient
astrologers and i imagine that they were
basically strategy consultants for kings
and so on who were like
kind of um discussing well
you know
what actually you know should you should
you go to battle at this point or not
you know let me be a consultant
and
uh give you an opinion about that
but the consultants had a certain amount
of hocus pocus around them
that involved you know
extracting entrails from goats and uh
making elaborate pronouncements i mean
the same with the delphic oracle um you
know people would come from all over the
ancient world to consult the delta
oracle um
and there was i think a high degree of
kind of um sort of hocus pocus around
that process
but in the end
the and i think the oracle the delphic
oracle had the big advantage that people
from all over the ancient world had come
to see it
so and come to see the people there so
they've been hearing about oh you know
there's this person from asia minor
who's worrying about this thing and
there's this person from north africa
who's worrying about this thing it might
have been the only place in the ancient
world where all of those different kinds
of uh uh
you know all the information from all
those different places came together so
it made for sort of a a good consulting
opportunity but i tend to think of the
astrologers as being
somewhat sort of uh uh you know wise
consultants with a certain dash of hocus
pocus and i'm a little bit reminded
of modern consulting you know some kinds
of strategy consulting and so on where
people say we're using the such and such
method you know it's the uh it's not
entrails of a goat but it's some other
kind of branded method so to speak that
um sort of uh uh sounds
uh sounds cool
but really in the end it's like you're
gonna be able to get a good result if
you have good judgment
and uh
you know you think well and so on and
the hocus pocus part of it is just
uh to bring those eyeballs to your
website or whatever um and i think that
that might have been very much uh well i
hate to think of the more literal form
of of um
dissecting creatures for um i'm bringing
eyeballs to things but let's not go
there um from uh in the ancient world
but i kind of think it was the same same
sort of thing i mean it's kind of
shocking to me the extent to which these
kind of human features
of you say oh you know the modern
consultant is so different from anything
that existed before it's just not true
you know these people like that were the
people like that all over the
throughout history i mean like i
mentioned machiavelli he was a
consultant basically uh a strategy
consultant to kings and so on um and uh
the you know
um as as many people in the ancient
world were for example
so i think um
uh
um
that's uh
uh i you know with respect to uh
sometimes there are things like alchemy
that last a long time
where
the some of their methods might actually
have been exactly what was needed
to uh
uh to refine metals and things like this
but it had a certain layer of of hocus
pocus that was all about turning you
know lead into gold and so on which
didn't turn out to pan out
um i you know i tend to think most of
the time that when there are enough
people doing something that there's
probably something interesting there
even if it isn't the thing that people
have been sort of touting as the
interesting thing i mean it's uh goes
along with kind of the idea that um uh
you know when something
notable finally gets done
uh in the world there's often something
quite interesting and difficult involved
in doing it and it isn't just the kind
of and it often isn't the superficial
uh
you know oh
um
that person was so cool so they could do
this it was some much more much deeper
much more intellectual kind of thing
that made it possible
um
maybe i can try
and um
let's see but there's one question that
came in here
um
about uh
maybe i should address this a different
time
uh about independent science maybe i'll
address it next week
um
that's sort of a different topic here
uh
there's one question here i'm going to
try and address this
my last thing for today from aaron how
has your view of the future changed over
the past 40 years
that is an interesting question
you know first i've i've tried to test
myself
by
trying to
remember
things that i thought would be the
future
um
and uh
see whether i was right about them
i think
you know
perhaps
well over the past 40 years i've seen a
lot of things which
were just
murmurs of what might be possible turn
into
big things that were important in the
world
and seeing that has been very
interesting because when i see a murmur
today the question is will it turn into
a big thing in the world or will it just
go silent
and
i think that perhaps
i've realized that sometimes the murmurs
take longer than you could possibly
imagine to turn into real things in the
world
and
i've also kind of realized
that i mean a lot of stuff i've done
myself
i kind of was thinking well people are
going to really understand this real
soon now
but i've realized that real soon is 50
years 100 years
the time scales for the absorption of
ideas are longer than i than i imagined
but
what happens is specific kind of slices
of those ideas specific kind of
uh you know
change life for the world
in some specific way
those things come in quickly but the
sort of bigger
intellectual sort of uh
arcs take a surprisingly long time to to
come to fruition in my in my observation
i mean i think
uh
the
there were things that i believed 40
years ago and believed today
i mean it's kind of like
uh computation
is getting to be everywhere
and is sort of the big story i mean
today i kind of i'm pretty sure that
it's computation all the way down in our
physical universe
i think that uh this really is
a
sort of a key paradigm for understanding
things in the world
um and i thought that 40 years ago i
think that even more so today
um
quite what the working out of that
paradigm will lead to
all over
is
it's not clear i mean to me
i think the thing that's happened is
what's one of the things that's
interesting about computation it's a
very general kind of thing yet many of
applica its applications have been very
specific like we might be doing you know
video conferencing that's being done on
general purpose computers but the actual
sequence of trans of operations that are
being done is very specific to video
conferencing and the fact that there are
all these things that ended up being
these little sort of towers of
capability that were made possible by
what was some
basically sort of general computers
is is something that i sort of expected
but it probably happened more than i
than i thought it would i mean of course
something like video conferencing is a
thing for which there were murmurs
you know back from the 1960s and 1950s
and before i was certainly very well
aware of it and i was like that's going
to happen in the end
just like you know flying cars will
happen in the end
even though
you know when they would happen wasn't
clear
i mean i was sort of a little bit
embarrassed to find things that i'd done
when i was a kid in the 1960s where i
was kind of assuming there'd be a colony
on mars
by the 1980s or so
and that time scale was completely wrong
but you know will there eventually be a
colony on mars undoubtedly you know what
is its time scale
longer than i than i had ever imagined
uh i think that um
um
you know in terms of
the
um
uh you know i i think
i think there are
aspects of the future that maybe i
understand a little bit more clarity now
that have to do with the sort of
interface between technology and humans
and particularly
the extent to which we humans and
biology
are an example of molecular scale
computing
and the extent to which when we can do
microscale computing we will have this
quite different form of interface to our
sort of human existence than we've ever
had before and i think that the um uh
that is likely to lead to all sorts of
discontinuities
in kind of what happens in the future
that are
you know quite unpredictable to me now
i i would say that well 40 years ago i
was just
coming upon this idea of computational
irreducibility this idea that just
because you know the rules by which
something operates doesn't mean you can
kind of jump ahead and figure out what
will happen
and the extent to which that would play
out
in kind of the unexpected in history uh
i actually knew that i began to know
that
uh certainly by the mid 1980s i was
quite quite aware of that issue um
uh of course i still
uh sought to kind of predict things
about the future even though at some
level i expected computational
irreducibility to limit what i could
really say about the future but um
you know i i'm trying to think what
other
uh
i mean it really is so interesting to
see these things that start as murmurs
and then become kind of all around us
uh and and to go back
once something has become big
and to see there was a seed of that
thing
and i suppose in my own life
uh one of the things i've tried to do is
not ignore the seeds
and
uh you know know at least a bit about
those seeds even if i'm not personally
involved in in nurturing and growing
those seeds
so that uh sort of when the seeds start
to really emerge
i'm not completely surprised like oh my
gosh i never expected that
um it would be possible to you know
transfer one voice to another using some
automated ai system well of course i
believe that's possible you know i've
seen demos it's not yet a routine thing
to do but it certainly will be possible
um or you know of course
it's uh
uh you know there are things that um
involve just
extracting information from ever and
ever sort of more
uh tenuous and finer details you know
will it ever be possible to know every
single
time that you know some
my you know my computer has been touched
through its history by looking at the
precise configuration of atoms not sure
about that one but i think it's a maybe
it's definitely not a slam dunk no
um
it's um it depends on on lots of details
whether that's whether that's possible
uh
so in any case i think um
uh
yeah so i'm trying to think what um if
you'd asked me
what do i think
what's the most surprising thing about
today's world
relative to 40 years ago well
many aspects of i mean i didn't i didn't
expect
i didn't expect what the web has turned
into
the concept of some kind of networked
computer thing
was very familiar with 40 years ago
um
the fact that
i was even familiar with kind of
personal computers the fact that more
people will be using computers over the
course of time
but
the kind of
sort of
lots of what happens in the world moves
over
into kind of the web sphere
i don't think i would have expected that
i don't think i'm
trying to
i don't think i really thought about it
very much i knew i used computers i used
email i used these kinds of things
and
if you'd asked me would everybody be
using this at some point in the future
back at that time i probably would have
said yeah i would expect so
um you know as computers get cheaper etc
etc i would expect so
uh
um
so but i wouldn't necessarily have
internalized sort of the major dynamics
of of sort of human affairs
that have
uh not that they're that different from
what happened before but they're
differently played out
in this kind of web environment
um i think that's uh yeah
um
10x comments
most surprising is that so many people
are using the internet for watching cat
videos
you know
this is a funny thing because i used to
use cats as an example of amusing
pictures of things forever maybe
everybody did i don't know um but you
know i started making kind of
uh
but long before cat videos became like a
a meme type thing
it just seemed like that was a fun thing
to watch in a little snippet of video
it's a you know it's a cat video um
the uh
um
i think uh
uh
um
so it was truly amusing to me when cat
videos became such a big thing
um i i should probably find some of the
things that i you know places where i
used you know cat video as an example
type thing
um
but uh
yeah i mean that was some
um
the fact that
mean look there are things that
surprised me like like an example is
this
uh you know
one would think over the course of time
that if one could have sort of very high
resolution video everybody will be into
you know watching movies in the highest
resolution video possible video possible
and some people are but also people
watch videos on their phones
and
i never thought that sort of the the
downgrading for convenience thing would
be as significant as it has been
that is even though it's tiny
might be fairly high resolution but it's
tiny and doesn't have sort of the same
plush form factor
as uh that that giant movie screen the
convenience wins out over quality so to
speak
and uh yeah that that's a
that's a thing somewhat unexpected to me
um
okay and and alexander concludes here
maybe cats are the aliens well yeah i
mean that this is the you know cats have
an alien view of the world
no doubt
i mean i haven't been able to talk to a
cat to determine that for sure
but i'm strong
strongly expect that cats
dogs
you know dogs are using smell as a way
to understand the world that's a very
different view of the world from the one
that we tend to have
um you know there are um no doubt
uh
you know
the cat cat philosophy
uh
might be um you know vastly different
from you know the cat uh
the the cat condition is surely a bit
different from the human condition we
share certain things with cats but other
things we don't share with cats
and um
um you know i think this is the this is
the big mystery if we could talk to cats
how would the conversation go you know
is the cat condition similar to the
similar enough to the human condition
that we could have a reasonable and
interesting discussion with the cat or
the cat just be saying
you know
uh
you know
uh
sort of
squiggling mouse straight mouse
uh
you know
you know a long stream of of mousiness
so to speak
um that we just like i don't know what
you're talking about you know just looks
like a mouse to me
um or whatever it is
or or something about how
um
it's uh
uh
you know some some kind of hunting
uh concept
um
the uh
um
that um
has uh
um
uh you know where
where
we'd be mystified now we might be
mystified if we were to to trail some
human hunter who is uh you know paying
attention to that strange little track
or that strange sound that we don't
necessarily notice
that might be a bit of a similar
experience
to you know talking to the experienced
you know
uh indigenous person
somewhere who is a great hunter of this
or that thing and who learn who knows
how to kind of read the forest to know
this or that might be an experience not
unlike the experience of of trying to
communicate with you know with a cat or
something who is very sort of concerned
with hunting things
and you know we might have as difficult
a time but it might be an easier
exercise because you know the the pure
mechanics of speech
would be shared and and other aspects of
the human condition will be shared but
it's sort of an interesting experiment
perhaps to try and imagine what it would
be like to you know be uh be having a
serious philosophical discussion with a
cat all right i think that's uh that's a
sign by the time we're talking about
serious philosophical discussions with
cats i think it's time to uh to wrap
this up so thanks very much for all
those interesting questions and comments
and
see you again another time and i think
this friday we have my doing it almost
every week for the last uh two and a
half years
uh
science and technology q a for kids and
others it will be the 100th episode of
that coming up this friday so uh
tune in if you'd like to see that
all right great thanks and uh bye for
now
you